and in the aftermath of the deadliest
mass shooting in modern US history we're
focusing on some of the people who stood
up and helped others that night one of
them is a US Marine veteran his name is
Taylor Winston instead of leaving the
scene to escape the gunfire
he helped victims and drove more than 20
of them to the hospital
Noro Donald's with us once again from
Las Vegas with his story Nora thank
goodness there are always stories like
this in times like this Gail you are
absolutely right we are reminded of the
humanity really good people as well that
do so much in the face of such tragedy
and the man we met last night had
remarkable poise less than 24 hours
after the attack and Taylor Winston told
us how he loaded some of the most
critical victims into a stolen truck he
stole the truck and then he sped it to
Desert Springs hospital Medical Center
all before ambulances had arrived on the
scene a friend got a few drinks and we
found our other friends near the side
stage and we just kind of posted up
there to watch and enjoy the concert
Taylor Winston and girlfriend Jen Lewis
were dancing the two-step stage right
moments later the gunfire began people
start scattering and screaming and
that's when we knew something real was
happening Winston and Lewis and
thousands of others needed to get to
safety but were boxed in by a fence the
shots got louder and louder closer just
and saw people getting hit it was like
we could be hit in any second once we
got to the fence helped throw a bunch of
people over and got myself over there's
a mini war zone but we couldn't fight
back the 29 year old veteran couldn't
fight the threat but he was able to
drive I saw a field with a bunch of
white trucks I tested my luck to see if
any of them had keys in it and first one
that we tried opening had keys sitting
right there and started looking through
people to take to the hospital there was
just too many and it was overwhelming
how much blood was everywhere victims
squeezed into the backseat and spread
across the bed of the truck
once we dropped him off we were like
let's go back for round two and go get
some more I transported probably 20 or
30 people injured to
Hospital Winston joined the Marines at
age 17 eventually serving two tours in
Iraq in 2011 he was honorably discharged
as a sergeant I think a lot of my
training in the military helped me in
the situation we needed to get them out
of there regardless of our safety
Winston rejects the hero label he said
he saw many people like him doing good
deeds there was a lot of bravery being
courageous people out there and I'm glad
that can call them my country folk just
think about that I mean Winston says
he's just 100% lucky that he was not
injured or killed many returned the keys
to the owner of the truck last night
that he stole it was all worth it
Winston says he doesn't know which of
his passengers survived but he feels
confident that his decision made a big
difference